[Applause]
all right thank you so much thank you
thank you i when they called my name I
had this feeling I could hear half of
America go y'all know how my why her
again you know but whatever first time
any thank dawn because when you thank
your husband at the end of the speech
they play them out with the music and I
want him to know that everything I value
most in our lives you've given me and
now secondly my other partner 37 years
ago my first play in New York City
I met the great hair stylist and makeup
artist Roy Helland and we we worked
together pretty continuously since the
day we clapped eyes on each other he his
first film with me was Sophie's Choice
and all the way up to tonight when he
won for his beautiful work in the Iron
Lady 30 years later every single movie
in between
and I just want to thank ro but also I
want to thank because I really
understand I'll never be up here again I
I really want to thank all my colleagues
all my friends I look out here and you
know it's I see my life before my eyes
my old friends my new friends and really
this is such a great honor but the thing
that counts the most with me is the
friendships and the love and the sheer
joy we have shared making movies
together my friends thank you all of you
departed and here for this
you know inexplicably wonderful career
thank you so much thank you
[Applause]